[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a la entrevista
de france 24 hoy está con nosotros un
ciclista de talla mundial campeón del
giro de italia en 2019 y el pedalista
latinoamericano de mejor rendimiento
esta temporada desde el carchi para el
mundo richard arcara paz muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros bienvenido
cuando como estas un gusto poder charlar
contigo hoy en este día gracias richard
estás en tu tierra descansando después
de una temporada que ha tenido mucha
intensidad sobre todo en estos últimos
meses como en esos días de descanso cómo
se vive la navidad allá en tu tierra en
el carchi
bueno si no desde que terminamos la
temporada en españa estoy aquí ya en
ecuador
con la familia y disfrutando de los
momentos y sobre todo bueno ahora que ya
estamos en época navideña
nada simplemente tratar de pasar lo más
agradable posible
richard desde estos momentos de calma de
tranquilidad cómo analizás tu primera
temporada con el ine o si llegaste para
ser líder a una de las escuadras más
poderosas del mundo tú cumpliste con las
expectativas que te habías fijado
y bueno para mí la verdad que este año
ha sido muy especial sobre todo con todo
lo que hemos vivido pero no he perdido
el enfoque la idea de tratar de mejorar
año a año y este año pues no ha sido la
excepción
con lo mejor que hemos podido conseguir
en este año el haber ido al tour de
francia- y poder haber terminado en una
muy buena manera y luego una vuelta
españa la verdad que creo que hemos
confirmado para lo que estamos hechos no
entonces simplemente espectacular esta
temporada con el equipo la verdad que
muy contento por todo el gran
rendimiento que hemos tenido a lo largo
de esta última temporada se critica
mucho lo que pasó con delineó es que es
una de las escuadras más poderosas como
bien decía con un presupuesto muy grande
y finalmente se llevaron una de las tres
grandes vueltas con esa victoria de taba
kevin hart en el giro de italia pero se
criticaba mucho el rendimiento del
equipo por lo que pasó con el gane se
abandonó por el no protagonismo que
tuvimos de chris froome y de guérin
tomás dentro del equipo cuál es el
sentir después de esta temporada 2020
así como te decía en un inicio la verdad
que ha sido un año muy especial para
todos y creo que al enfrentarnos al
haber estado este tiempo en casa no
habernos podido preparar de una manera o
también
de haberse pasado un poco con el rodillo
yo creo que ha influido mucho en varios
perdedores del equipo entonces bueno por
mi parte yo creo que
esperamos que el año que viene vamos a
estar todos a la altura y bueno no me
quedo sobretodo con mi rendimiento que
ha sido espectacular así eso fue ha sido
un buen rendimiento y me imagino que tú
este
2020 lo vas a recordar sobre todo por
esa participación en el tour de francia
de la que nos hablaba algo histórico no
solamente para ti sino para ecuador
primera participación de un ecuatoriano
en un tour de francia- y te tocó no sé
si a la mala suerte richard de un tour
de francia que se corrió rapidísimo e
fue más difícil de lo que esperabas
la verdad que este año hemos tenido la
oportunidad de ir a conocer el tour
tenía muchas ganas de hacerlo y bueno ha
coincidido la temporada y la verdad que
si no ha sido un tour bastante bastante
duro con gente que ha ido muy bien
preparada muy fuerte y eso ha hecho pues
que el día a día sea más agonizante pero
bueno de cara al final yo sabía que en
un principio no iba a ir al 100% y va a
ir poco a poco cogiendo la forma y de
cara a la última semana pues la verdad
es mente estar siendo protagonista el
haber portado una camiseta en el turn
para mí ha sido muy especial y algo muy
bonito porque no solo puedo vestir la
malla de lunares sino también he estado
en la pelea durante tres etapas en busca
de la victoria y bueno lo hemos podido
conseguir por mi compañero
se aplicó la etapa y eso pues para mí es
algo muy especial no yo creo que en mi
primer tour al haber dejado ya un nombre
una huella hace que el año que viene si
podemos estar en el tour base algo muy
especial no conociendo ya cómo es la
carrera tuvo muchísima importancia para
el equipo me imagino esa victoria de
etapa después de todo lo que pasó toda
la mala suerte que hubo caídas etcétera
que te dijo mi amigo que tops que cuando
le dejaste ganar esa etapa esa foto tan
bonita de ustedes dos cruzando la meta
y la verdad que ha sido algo muy
especial para nosotros no ha vuelto para
el equipo porque otra vez volví a la
felicidad se podría decir no siempre el
estar presente es dando batalla y el
haber podido lograr esta etapa es muy
algo muy bonito no y la foto es para el
recuerdo no
creo que mi hijo era el hombre más feliz
en ese momento porque él también ha
tenido que sacrificar muchos títulos a
nivel personal ya que el día encontrarse
con esta etapa yo creo que la vuelta
otra vez no a él el sentirse corredor
disputando una etapa el por su parte
simplemente podemos saber que era el
hombre más feliz seguro que sí richard
el recorrido del tour para el próximo
año lo conocemos nos conocimos el de la
vuelta y el giro pero el tour ya sabemos
que tiene tres llegadas en alto dos
contrarrelojs muy grandes y tú has
mejorado muchísimo en la crono pero a
priori ese recorrido del tour del
próximo año no se muestra como muy
adaptado a tu perfil que crees
y bueno si no hemos estado ya analizando
un poco lo que va a ser el tory y es
verdad no
así que he mejorado en varios aspectos y
este año queremos seguirlo haciendo
queremos seguir mejorando detalles que
nos quedan por pulir pero pero bueno no
es verdad que no puede ser un recorrido
probable pero tampoco no descartable que
podamos asistir al tour dependería mucho
también del recorrido del toro y de
donde el giro y de la vuelta para poder
decidir a qué gran vuelta
asistiremos este año efectivamente falta
por conocer esos recorridos pero de
manera tentativa entre el equipo tienen
en cuenta que hay un nuevo ganador de
una gran vuelta que está o ya se ha
hablado de manera adelantada o ya mí me
gustaría correr esta carrera qué tal si
tú vas a esta otra
todavía no hemos tenido la verdad que
ahora mismo en el periodo descanso
estamos desconectando todo lo que tenga
que ver por la bici y bueno ahora yo
creo que
disfrutar este momento pero pero si no
yo creo que cuando sepamos ya los
recorridos oficiales de las tres grandes
vueltas ya nos sentaremos con el equipo
a hablarlo y sobre todo analizar todos
los recorridos y cuál puede ser uno que
le podamos dar prioridad el año que
viene ya hablamos del tour demandamos de
manera cronológica hablemos ahora de la
vuelta españa porque te quedase muy
cerca de ganar de nuevo a primos son
robles y el todopoderoso esloveno de que
hace a 24 segundos de repetir esa
victoria de volver a ganar a primos
estuvo muy cerca a richard
sí bueno yo creo que fue una vuelta muy
especial desde el primer día que
iniciamos en irún y sobre todo pues ya
década madrid creo que ha sido una una
batalla
del todo desde el inicio y la verdad que
muy contento no me quedo con ese con el
sabor dulce en la boca del haber estado
ahí otra vez luchando con el mejor
ciclista de la temporada y sobre todo
que creo que van a venir años mejores y
poder estar ahí en la lucha que pues que
nos motivemos más y que tengamos mucho
más se podría decir muchas más ganas no
de volver a hacerlo que lo que hemos
venido haciendo ya te digo yo creo que
espectacular la vuelta ha tenido pues
varios protagonistas y sobre todo que
nos hemos tenido que volver a encontrar
comprimimos en una en una próxima
ocasión tenemos que hablar de esto a
richard penúltima etapa alto de la
covatilla llegue a estar en la
clasificación virtual de acuerdo a 18
segundos del liderato primero glitch se
muestra prácticamente escoltado por
enric más y marc soler crees que si esto
no hubiera ocurrido si el hecho hubiera
estado sobre esos dos últimos kilómetros
el resultado de la vuelta hubiera sido
otro
yo creo que fueron situaciones de
carrera y no me he puesto a pensarlo de
esa manera que si podía ganar o no no
simplemente yo hice lo que estaba a mi
mano y lamentablemente pues nos quedamos
con ese poquito que nos faltó no creo
que
creo que sobre todo demostramos que
éramos corredores agresivos y que no
dejamos
no estamos tan libre la carrera el
último que se pensaba que podía
sentenciar se pero por mi parte yo me
quedo muy contento por el gran
rendimiento que he tenido y bueno como
te digo no me puesto a pensar si podría
ganar o no si no hubiese influido lo de
movistar pero sabes que se ha hablado
muchísimo acerca de esta maniobra e
incluso se dice en los medios especula
que si tú crees que hay alguna relación
entre esa maniobra y la salida tuya y de
andrey amador del año pasado del
movistar
bueno pienso que no no lo quiero pensar
y espero que no sea así en su momento yo
hablé con los corredores del equipo y
bueno no simplemente ellos estaban
jugando subasta del cuarto lugar y no lo
hacían a intención de tal vez de querer
molestarme o quería interrumpir en lo
que yo también buscaba no son
situaciones de carrera y todo totalmente
es muy entendible lo que sucedió en
aquel día richard cambiamos de tema
cómo está el ciclismo en ecuador a cada
vez termina la vuelta en ecuador tenemos
a un campeón santiago montenegro tenemos
también a miriam núñez que es
ecuatoriana y acaba de ganar la vuelta
femenina a colombia y futuro en ecuador
sí bueno yo creo que después de todo lo
que se ha venido realizando en los
últimos años el ecuador ha tenido
protagonismo nacional internacional y
sobre todo ha puesto con estos dos
jóvenes sobre todo lo de miriam que fue
muy especial lo que había
haya podido haya podido triunfar en
colombia y luego pues lo de la vuelta al
ecuador sí que sí que ha sido sorpresa
para todos porque creo que era una
vuelta que no se esperaba y al final de
todo se ha podido realizar pero bueno al
ecuador todavía le queda mucho por
trabajar en la niñez en la juventud
porque sí que necesitamos tener por lo
menos la siguiente década tener más
representantes a nivel internacional qué
cosas se deberían mejorar qué más hay
que hacer para que ese talento explote
bueno la licuadora ahora mismo no tiene
un calendario sobre todo nacional el
lunes que carrera que se sabe que puede
existir es la vuelta al ecuador y todas
las demás siempre han sido la última
hora o a veces ni constan en el
calendario nacional yo creo que hay que
tener un trabajo coordinado con la
ecuatoriana y las federaciones nada
federaciones provinciales para que tenga
tengamos los ciclistas entonces eso es
lo que ahora mismo le hace falta
también se echa mucho de menos que no
hagan clubes de formación actualmente en
el país el ciclismo de ruta hay tres de
los cuales están reconocidos a través de
la federación y del resto del país se
echa mucho de menos esto no
y lamentablemente pues creo que no vamos
a tener ciclistas a la altura si se deja
esto a un lado richter pero aún así en
el jugador la pasión por el ciclismo se
puede decir que ha ido en aumento yo
recuerdo en 2019 cuando ganaste el giro
que la televisión nacional ecuatoriana
no transmitía el giro y que tuvo que
comprar las dos últimas etapas de
recuerdo haber visto la televisión de su
país y explicaban mucho en qué función
en qué consistía el giro de italia las
grandes vueltas pero ahora de la mano
tuya de la mano de tus compatriotas yo
no tener vice jonathan caicedo está
empezando a despertarse una pasión por
el ciclismo
si no bueno después de la última gesta
de adquisición en 2019
sí que es cierto que los ecuatorianos
han visto en el ciclismo como como un
deporte bandera no porque
lamentablemente pues siempre han estado
presente los deportes tradicionales que
a lo mejor no han podido brindar las
alegrías que han podido brindar nuestros
nuestros ciclistas y por mi parte
también no
esperemos que siga así el crecimiento es
muy importante para todos para cuanto
para toda la niñez y sobre todo que ese
pequeño granito de arena que todo el
mundo está que está sumando va a ser
importante para para todo esperemos que
sea así de richard muchísimas gracias
por este tiempo te deseamos lo mejor
para esta próxima temporada esperamos
que sea un poco más regular para todo el
ciclo y también para todo el deporte y
gracias richard y gracias también a
ustedes por haber estado con nosotros
aquí en france24 quédense porque más en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]